Traza la recta que representa una relación
proporcional entre "y" y "x"
donde la tasa unitaria de cambio
de "y" respecto a "x" es 1 con 2/3.
En otras palabras, un cambio de 1 unidad en "x"
corresponde a un cambio de 1 con 2/3
de unidades en "y".
Escribe la ecuación de la recta.
Bueno, déjenme copio esto en un lugar donde
pueda escribir.
Muy bien, ahora, recuerden que estamos trabajando
con una relación proporcional,
por lo tanto es de la forma "y"
es igual a una constante "k" por "x".
Y vamos a hacer una pequeña tabla, para tratar de entender como se comporta esta relación proporcional.
Si "x" vale 0, entonces no importa cuanto
valga "k", "y" siempre tiene que valer 0,
porque la relación es proporcional, "k" por 0 siempre
va a ser 0, así que el punto 0, 0,
tiene que estar en la gráfica de mi relación proporcional,
este punto de aquí está en la gráfica en la relación.
Ahora, si aumento a "x" en 1, entonces
¿cuánto tiene que aumentar "y"?
Pues me están diciendo que un cambio
de 1 unidad en "x",
corresponde a un cambio de 1 con 2/3 de unidades en "y". 1 con 2/3 es lo mismo que 5/3,
por lo tanto voy a usar 5/3, es más fácil trabajar con
fracciones impropias, 5/3, ok.
Si ahora vuelvo a aumentar a "x" en 1,
"x" ahora vale 2
entonces "y" tiene que volver
a aumentar en 5/3 de unidad.
Por lo tanto, ahora "y" vale 10/3 de unidad.
Ninguno de estos dos puntos
tiene coordenadas enteras,
así que graficarlo está un poco complicado.
Voy a volver a cambiar "x", ahora va a valer
3, aumenté 1 unidad, por lo tanto "y" aumenta
en 5/3 de unidad y ahora "y" vale 15/3, pero
15/3, es lo mismo que 5, 15 entre 3 es 5.
De modo que el punto, 3, 5 está
en la gráfica de mi relación.
La gráfica de mi relación, relación proporcional,
por lo tanto se vería algo así...
algo así, más o menos...
Bien, entonces, noten que para... noten... entonces,
noten que cada vez que cambié a
"x" en 1 unidad, "y" cambió 5/3...
cuando "x" cambió en 1 unidad, "y" aumentó en 5/3...
también de aquí a acá y se corresponde
con el mismo cambio acá.
Bueno, y ¿cuál es la pendiente de esta recta?
Pues, la pendiente es el alza entre el avance,
el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x".
Aquí yo tengo un cambio en "x", un cambio
en "x"de 3 unidades, paso de valer 0...
de valer 0 a valer 3, por lo tanto es como si
me viniera de aquí hasta acá,
mi cambio en "x" es de 3 unidades y mi cambió en "y",
¿de cuánto es?
Pues paso de valer 0, a valer 5, por lo tanto
mi cambio en "y" es de 5.
También lo podría haber leído aquí en
la tabla, sería como ir de aquí...
del 0 hasta este 5... el cambio en "y" es de 5.
De modo que la pendiente que se define como
el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x"...
el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x", sería de...
¿pues cuánto es el cambio en "y"?
es de 5, ¿y el cambio en "x? es de 3,
por lo tanto la pendiente sería
de 5/3, que es lo mismo que 1 con 2/3,
esto de aquí... esto de aquí es precisamente
la pendiente de la recta.
Ahora, para encontrar la ecuación, pues yo
sé que la ecuación de la recta, es de esta forma de aquí.
Por lo tanto, tomando cualesquiera de estas
parejas de valores,
puedo sustituirlas acá y deducir en valor de "k".
Si "x" vale 3... si "x" vale 3, entonces "y"
vale 5, de modo que 5... 5,
es igual a "k" por "x", pero "x" en este caso vale 3.
Si ahora yo divido todo entre 3... divido
toda esta ecuación entre 3... entre 3...
entre 3... este 3 se cancela con este 3 y
obtengo que "k"es igual a 5/3.
De modo que la ecuación se convierte en
"y" es igual a 5/3 de "x".
Vamos a verificarlo, regresando al sitio,
teníamos el punto 0, 0 y el punto 3, 5...
3, 5...
Y la ecuación era "y" es igual a 5/3 de "x".
Vamos a checar la respuesta...
Y estamos en lo correcto.